it's a popular notion that our modern
lifestyles are not compatible with
optimal health
that the routines we go through every
single day are actually harming our
well-being
with an hour spent in the gym being
inadequate to reverse that damage
this is something i agree with and have
communicated in the past
our bodies adapt to the lifestyles we
present them with our capacity to adapt
is intended to ensure
that we're able to thrive in the
environment we find ourselves in
this is the main stimulus for adaptation
not the three hours a week we spent
lifting weights or running on treadmills
of course training this way can help to
mitigate some of the damage caused by a
lethargic lifestyle
but it's just a small splash in the
ocean and because we're often trying to
make up for our bad lifestyle habits in
just a couple of hours
we often push ourselves too hard and end
up getting injured
nor is the hyper specialization of
sports specific training a suitable
antidote
this is one reason for the sudden
pronounced trend towards primal health
get out of the office and out of the gym
and start crawling around the woods in
the cold
well i think this type of training has a
lot of merit and i'll be covering that
soon on this channel
i also think it slightly misses the
point after all there's no single
environment that shaped our entire
evolution
while it's true that our environments
have changed faster than our biological
evolution in the last few centuries
leading to many of the issues we're
talking about here it's also true that
we're capable of adapting
to different environments as i've said
many times on this channel
kyphosis isn't really maladaptive if it
means you can sit and type for longer
you've simply adapted to your lifestyle
the problem is that our lifestyle is so
rote in many cases and so static that
this becomes all we're capable of
the issue is that we have changed our
environment to be as comfortable as
possible
to the point where we rarely need to
bend over let alone lift anything heavy
or climb
but when everything is comfortable and
predictable we never have to get outside
our comfort zone which of course is
where growth
occurs there's a co-evolution between
environment and organism
and this is what we missed in designing
the modern lifestyle
so the answer may not be to return to a
more natural way of living
but rather just to find ways to
challenge ourselves throughout the day
potentially we could create environments
that lead to even more performance
benefits and useful adaptations than
those natural ones without any of the
downsides
natural doesn't automatically mean
better but we need to be smart about
introducing these new ideas
this is how we will design the shape of
humanity to come i believe
even before transhuman technologies take
over
so to do this we must start by fully
understanding and addressing the
shortcomings of our current routines
here are just some of the ways that
modern life harms our health and
performance
so at 6am you've been asleep for about
five and a half hours when the alarm
starts blaring
loudly in your ear you're startled out
of deep sleep
the reason that alarms are designed to
sound like they do is that there's no
natural sound like a beep or a buzz
it therefore triggers a fight or flight
response that pulls you out of deep
sleep
that's right your heart is now beating
faster and your blood is circulating
cortisol and adrenaline what a way to
start the day
and because you were pulled out of such
a deep sleep you may well be
experiencing sleep inertia
your back may be weak and soft from
sleeping on it especially if your
mattress is soft and your lower back has
been allowed to sag into the mattress
your internal body clock is probably
entirely confused as it's likely dark in
your room
now in a state of physiological stress
and time displacement you may head into
the kitchen for a mug of coffee
caffeine molecules bind to the adenosine
receptors in your brain
waking you up by blocking some of the
substance that causes tiredness in the
first place
this doesn't get rid of it it only
causes it to build up as though it were
behind a dam
and if this is a regular habit then
you'll actually increase your adenosine
receptors
another cause of morning grogginess is
actually thought to be caffeine
withdrawal
so that's super healthy and that coffee
also causes even more of a sympathetic
response increasing cortisol and
adrenaline
even further coffee is essentially
stress in a cup not judging by the way i
love coffee like kel loves orange soda
next you might pour yourself a bowl of
cereal that cereal may well be high in
sugar and low in nutrients
it's a bowl of empty calories meaning
you aren't getting the vitamins minerals
and amino acids that you need to sustain
healthy bone and muscle
you'll get specific cravings throughout
the day as your body tries to replace
those missing elements
the sugar not buffered by any complex
carbohydrates or fats hits your body
like a freight train
that causes a sudden spike in sugar and
insulin that over time could contribute
to insulin resistance
it also means that once you burn through
that sugar around 10 30 am say
you'll have a crash and become extremely
sluggish and lethargic
did you know that one of the only
universal stresses as people moving
towards you people from every single
culture show a stress response when
another person walks at them
so yeah pushing your way down a crowded
street during rush hour is no good for
you
even before covered 19. you may then sit
in a dull grey cubicle and start typing
away
you are bombarded at this point by
constant mild stresses
the light from the screen even slightly
increasing your heart rate the big ones
though are those phone calls more
buzzing and emails from your boss
clients and customers each one of these
triggers yet more of a fight or flight
response as you worry about
things that are way outside of your
control this is a problem
stress is not bad for us the acute
stress response is in fact
a healthy response that prepares us for
an ensuing challenge
blood rushes to the brain and muscles so
we can think faster run quicker and
punch
harder meanwhile less pressing concerns
like digestion and immunity
are put on the back burner as blood is
rerouted away from those things
blood vessels constrict pupils dilate to
let in more light and blood viscosity
increases to prevent bleeding out in
case of injury
your muscles contract slightly
increasing strength heart rate increases
and so does breathing
fear is a superpower
[Music]
fear can make you faster and cleverer
and stronger this is all useful when it
lasts for 20 minutes to help you escape
a predator it is not useful when it
continues for five
days or five months when stress becomes
chronic
when your muscles tense up whilst you're
at work causing neck and head pain
and when you go for days at a time with
a lowered immunity and increased blood
pressure
it's no wonder that we're over trained
and sick or that we develop mood
disorders or obesity
especially as cortisol encourages the
storage of fat in all the wrong places
you're ready to fight and yet all you're
doing is sitting in your chair tense and
anxious
and it's not like many of us are
challenged by our work mentally either
maybe we were to start with when we
learned these new skills but for many of
us work has become rote and easy
this is a problem because it means our
brains become less plastic learning new
things
increases the production of bdnf and
other plasticity supporting chemicals
the more we learn the more we're able to
learn that's why the infant brain is so
highly plastic
while they are so infinitely capable of
learning and adapting because everything
is new
from learning to stand and walk to
learning to speak as we age we continue
learning new things whether it's dating
driving
new careers or the layout of new cities
but eventually we settle down we settle
into routines
barely ever are we challenged to learn
something new our body cements the
patterns it needs to maintain our
current skill
but loses the ability to pick up new
ones as they say you can't teach an old
dog new tricks
why because that old dog hasn't learned
a new trick in 30 years
it's not because it's inherently
incapable of learning new things
this cognitive decline is worsened by
deteriorating senses a loss of vision
hearing and smell
this reduces the amount of information
coming into your brain meaning there's
less to process
that's made worse by the fact that we
wear shoes with thick soles which deaden
the sense of proprioception
that we should be getting from our feet
of course there's little natural light
getting into the room
so vitamin d is depleted and bone
density is weakened
hours of poor posture caused that
forward hunch called kyphosis that we
talked about earlier
whilst tight hip flexors place
additional stress on an already
awkwardly under tensioned lumbar spine
when we do get up to move and get the
pen from across the other side of the
room
the most we can hope for is a couple of
minute walk
as i alluded to at the start of this
essay everything is designed to be at
standing height you never have to bend
down never have to jump or climb
when we get home we're often so tired
from the commuting from spending the
entire day slightly stressed
that we collapse onto the safe and watch
junk tv junk tv that nevertheless
stimulates us even more
thanks to those bright screens right
before we go to bed too late on a
stomach too full
so nope three hours in the gym doing
curls on a few heavy lifts entirely in
the frontal plane when exhausted already
from a busy week
is not enough to undo all of this damage
this may sound dramatic keep in mind i'm
just trying to make a point there are
actually many
beneficial aspects of modern life that
are fantastic for us
activities like driving and even
computer games stimulate the brain in
amazing and unique ways
we live longer than ever before and we
have access to huge amounts of
information thanks to the web
i made a whole video on this i'm not
trying to be a negative ninny
i'm just pointing out some of the
drawbacks of our current lifestyles
and why a little bit of training isn't
enough and if you're a stay-at-home mom
or dad if you're retired or if you're a
teenager
chances are that your lifestyle may not
resemble the one i just outlined
but i bet everyone can relate to at
least something on this list
so the point is that we need to consider
training in the broader context of our
lifestyles
this is where the real substantial
change will occur so just how do we do
that
here are some methods you can use to
mitigate the issues i addressed here
and some fixes that will make your
lifestyle more conducive to high
performance adaptations
try sleeping using a daylight alarm this
creates a faux sunrise to gently wake
you out of a deep sleep
sleep with a window open so that your
body can use temperature as a cue for
setting the biological clock
avoid caffeine after 4 pm have half an
hour of down time before bed
get outside first thing in the morning
ideally for quick meditation eat
nutrient dense foods
avoid foods that are overly processed
wear minimal footwear or even bare feet
sometimes take
regular breaks from work to get up and
stretch learn to manage stress again
meditation works wonders as does cbt
learn new skills and consider this a
crucial training play computer games no
really
consider a cold shower to train cold
exposure cycle to work
go for thought provoking walks get a
lumbar support cushion for your desk
chair
you can also employ methods to integrate
training into your daily routine
so that you're constantly moving and
regularly challenging the body i'm going
to make a whole video on this soon but
some examples are
keep a grip trainer by the kettle and
use it whilst the kettle boils
brush your teeth with your left hand
enjoy more physical play with your kids
if you need to go anywhere under a mile
away jog ideally work from home
i keep dip bars by my desk chair and do
regular dips planche training l-sit and
more
install a pull-up bar in your door and
perform pull-ups every time you pass
under it
i also personally like to stretch in the
shower as a dad it's one of the few
opportunities i get during the morning
routine
do things on the floor instead of a
table and use a resting squat
so that might mean talking on the phone
or reading perform mental math when
waiting perform overcoming isometrics
against your own body or against the
wall while waiting
train outside when you can and visit new
places i'd love to hear your suggestions
in the comments down below
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please consider leaving a like and
sharing it around
that helps me out immensely thanks so
much for your awesome support and to
everyone who suggested that james cover
my channel
over at shredded sports science he did
and it was awesome
i really respect his opinion so it was
hugely validating to get a thumbs up on
that video
you all rock oh and hi to anyone here
from that channel welcome aboard the
good ship bioneer of course if you like
the idea of taking a cohesive approach
to your physical and mental performance
that goes beyond a few constrained
movement patterns in the gym
then you may enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training
there i go into a lot of detail
discussing the mechanisms of the human
body
and how to train for cross-functional
performance it all ends with a training
program designed to build strength
mobility speed cognitive function and
more
there's a link in the description down
below and there's discount on right now
during the pandemic
hope you guys are doing great and i look
forward to catching you in the next one
thanks again and bye for now